the holidays are inching closer and
travelers are booking their flights to
visit their loved ones recently the cdc
released new guidelines to keep you safe
victoria saha joins us live from
mccarran international airport tonight
with what some there have to say
victoria
sasha as you get ready to pack your bags
for the holiday season make sure you
have your face coverings because the cdc
now recommends them that you wear your
face mask when gathering with your
family for the holiday season
as we near our second holiday season
during the cobin 19 pandemic many might
be ditching their zoom links used to
gather virtually for a plane ticket
instead this year the centers for
disease control came out with new
guidelines for this holiday season they
say on top of getting vaccinated make
sure you have your masks handy when
traveling or sharing laughs indoors with
family
mary brooks has family from all over
coming to visit for the holidays but
she's making sure everyone stays safe as
possible we have been really on the
family members that have not been
vaccinated
that is just
what we all should do i believe and as
she travels frequently she says safety
is her top priority i've noticed now
that there are more and more people that
are traveling even from then that point
i always try to get like a seat in
between me and the other passenger
though and for mom shayna craig the
recent flight from southwest
cancellations is making her rethink
their holiday travel plans so a normal
45 minute flight turned into like a four
hour travel day with the kids southwest
airlines issued a statement on the more
than 3 300 flight disruptions citing out
of place aircraft and strain on crews
it's important to remember if you are
gathering with people who are uneligible
to get the vaccine you can do your part
to get the kova 19 vaccine if you're
going to be celebrating with them
indoors reporting from mccarran
international airport victoria saha live
local now